this is the umbrella academy wrong again
this is the sparrow academy kind of
explain what you think happened
was there something in the timeline that
got messed up and what
is the sparrow academy oh yeah i mean i
think we all know that five
[ __ ] it up again yeah we really messed
up the timeline with all of our jumps
and existence in the 1960s for years so
when we arrive back at the academy it's
no longer our home
it's dressed slightly differently
because different people have been
living in it for years
and there's a whole new academy that
hargreaves set up first i'd imagine
their egos are going to be bruised
irrevocably there they were thinking
they were this
sort of unique band of snowflakes and i
suppose it also hints at the idea of
multiple universes
so they're possibly in a wrong universe
yeah you know i mean all of the
circumstances that they've
been dropped into seem to be as a result
of
the kind of a different history you know
and perhaps the kind of
you know the shattered glass theory of
multiple universes is that it is a
universe and then
an event occurs and then doesn't occur
which leads the universe to sort of
split into a
distorted mirror of itself so i would
imagine maybe
not that i know nothing that uh that
event was that ben
didn't die you know because there is a
sack of flesh with a trendy new haircut
there is this painting hanging in there
of ben
and i it seems like ben is part of the
sparrow academy so
what do you make of that situation and
where ben
ben's story will maybe possibly go is
that even been
i uh i think it is betty i you know i
thought as well he may not be called ben
because it depends whether um oh
mum called him the same name that he did
uh
in in our world but yeah i mean it's
interesting isn't it
i i don't we don't know if these kids
are
um part of the all the kids that were
born the same day or if it's a you know
if it's another bunch of those or we
don't know
who they are i think it'd be it would
lead us to believe that ben is
you know obviously the same and he's got
the same powers etc
but i like to think that ben is uh
is more powerful i suppose in in this
world
he's uh got more balls about him i
imagine could you have a different
name in a possible season three what do
you make of all of this
let's call you gregory
[Laughter]
they don't tell me anything so so
uh much of it is under wraps um
as was that last scene basically no one
knew about that final
scene until a couple of weeks before
we shot it and even then the script was
only sent to the cast it was not really
sent to anyone
so that was a completely closed set that
day everything was top secret
uh no one even knew uh you know that the
sparrow academy
uh existed so um in terms of what i can
tell you
not much but it is it is really exciting
obviously to be alive but also to be
able to sort of create a brand new
uh persona and character because this is
not the bend that we know
it's a completely different version of
that person
all right first off i want to say we
brought the end of the world back here
with us
oh my god again my cult he's gonna be so
pissed
i told him we had until 2019. i think
that
what happened was dad met six
crazy 30 year olds in the 60s
and decided to go and adopt those same
six kids because he figured out
uh that they would be obsolete
to him so he so i think the sparrow
academy is supposed to be
the a team compared to the beat team
that is the umbrella academy because
they hate each other and if you notice
sparrow academy even when you see them
come into that frame they look united
you know what i just realized yeah
this is probably something that steve
planted in the script five actually says
in season two is it too late to be
unadopted and by the end of the show
we're unadopted just notice this
that's some crazy foreshadowing what a
cruel father figure hargreaves was
you're alive why shouldn't i be let's
talk about
good old reginald because he's also
alive in present time which is pretty
shocking to the umbrella academy also in
the episode before the finale we see him
kind of
unmask so ellen do you think that he is
an alien
what what are we meant to believe it
looks like he might be
you know um it looks like that could be
the case
i absolutely love that twist and how it
was done
oh yeah you know what a thing to pull
off and
in a way that feels you know like
grounded and really
affects you and even just colem like the
way he moved his body and everything
i thought it was so fantastic but yeah i
mean
certainly seems to be what it looks like
do you think he's an
alien do you think that there's i didn't
think they were gonna go that
literal with the space alien thing but i
go yeah baby you know
we uh we we got the we got the nice
audience now let's uh
let's camp it up let's go a bit graphic
novel you know what i mean
is that something that we will learn
more about it in a potential season
three
what's what's going on with him well
when i saw that happening
that's my that's where i'm getting at at
least maybe season three right they'll
probably
dive into that more i would say that
mystery is always enticing
so they'll probably hide a lot more than
they show
but yeah the way i understood it steve
said
he is an alien but we're not going to
tell him until a future season
but they'll be like little easter eggs
and hints
of alien related things just so that
certain fans could pick up on that
tom do we think that there's any hope
for
for luther and allison in the future
should that be left in the past what are
your thoughts on
on that i think they will always have a
strong connection but i do think
i think i i am not upset if
we move on from that narrative yeah i
think
the romantic element yeah i think the
romantic element is sort of like a
season one thing and then i think it's
always going to be
leaned on a little bit especially their
connection and like and the thing is as
well like me and emily always
discussed this that it's so much more
than a physical thing for them it's like
it's a deep connection they have
because of their relationship as kids
and
they so heavily rely on each other so i
think we'll always see that and we'll
always see that relationship but i don't
know if
we'll ever see them in that light again
i'm not sure
what to do proper snog yeah
and also it made all the audience go
whoa yes
little game of thrones it was yeah yeah
twitter had twitter had a lot of
opinions
did you ever find a safe way back to me
you take it
you hear me
[Music]
ellen for you romance wise is there some
hope
in the future for vania and [ __ ] let's
you know most certainly hope they've
fallen uh incredibly in love um
you know i'm not sure of course
you know uh in terms of the future but
uh
as we see in the end she's driving off i
think
you know embracing a new life feeling
differently and embracing who she is
and um that's the most beautiful thing
to see
um we'll just have to wait and see yeah
what about the fact that harlan
seemingly still has his
his powers in the back seat of that car
as they head to i think it's new mexico
yeah or they're heading i think to
california and driving through new
mexico yeah um
uh well uh clearly yeah harlan has some
power
so i would imagine that's we're probably
gonna see uh
more of what that means at some point
she was looking for you
because you're one of us
the handler stole you lyla we met lyla
this season
and we realized that she can sort of
mirror or take on
everyone else's powers so what does that
mean
in terms of the umbrella academy do you
think that they have more powers that
are to be
unlocked do you think the sparrow
academy
is more powerful than the umbrella
academy you kind of talk about where you
see
things going in terms of powers both of
you yeah
you know i if only klaus would sort out
his diet you know his powers might
evolve if you just eat his porridge in
the morning
not not so much booze yeah not as much
whiskey and a bit more
smoothie yeah yeah
shape and the old belly but uh yeah
you know i think they have every up they
have every every chance of evolving
we've watched them evolve
here and there over the second series
you know my only thing about the powers
evolving is i
i wouldn't want to want them to get too
capable
you know because i think there's
probably a distinct
graph you could draw between capability
versus
drama you know what i mean
[Laughter]
i'd want to i'd want to keep render them
keep yeah
okay well for as long as i possibly
could so but i suppose you know
that said you you could have the most
delightful
airplane or whatever in the world but if
you're a
pilot or that's it you know you're not
really going to fly it straight
it's a good analogy justin what about
for you what do you think
i mean especially ben we haven't seen
much of his powers so where do you
where do you stand with all of this yeah
it's going to be really interesting to
see what
what ben can do when he's not dead i
think we got
a tiny moment of that in the first
season when he's younger and he sort of
takes out all of those
bad guys in the bank so it'll be
interesting to see
how that's evolved for him i also think
it's going to be so interesting again
if if season 3 is ago because this is
the first time that their
enemies have supernatural abilities i
mean
up until now they've been battling
assassins
and and uh you know really smart uh
violent people but they haven't really
dealt with people
like themselves other than isla uh who
have
uh the the supernatural abilities so
it's gonna be
really interesting and and i'm sure
gonna cause way more drama
i mean in episode 10 the fact that i was
bending bullets
that was that was a shock to me i have
an interesting nugget of information
steve hinted that when the siblings
are together in closer proximity
they get stronger and i don't know
whether or not that has something to do
with the 43 children and the spiritual
connection of
all of us or if it's simply of the fact
that we've been trained as a team
as an academy we know how to fight with
each other
you know these are people that grew up
training with so
yeah in terms of abilities i think
there's a lot of unexplored
ground that we can cover but yeah
we just we generally get more powerful
when we combine
forces is there anything that you guys
would love to see
in a potential season three each of you
maybe go around and
and one thing that you would be very
happy
if that were to be explored i'd like to
there's certain characters that i've not
really
like i didn't have many scenes with uh
with klaus last season actually and we
had some really great moments in season
one and uh i'd like to
because i want to make sure that you
know you get your time with every
character because i really enjoy those
individual moments and those individual
scenes with each of the characters so i
think it's
i'd like to always make sure that i get
you know time with each character
because i think that's one of the
beauties of the show seeing all the
different dynamics between each of them
and i also i would really be interested
in in allison kind of going on a journey
by herself i think um you know in
in you know three seasons of this show
she said
you're two seasons of the show she's had
three love interests and i think
um i kind of would be interested in in
an allison that um
is kind of finding a an independence
um kind of by herself and isn't kind of
caught up in some sort of
like romantic um
you know entanglement or or marriage or
um just kind of
i'm interested to see like what that
version of allison is and also like
now that they're back and clearly the
timeline is weird like where's claire
where is claire yeah so i think that's
i'm really i would love to like dive
into like the the mother
motherhood side of allison that we you
know you kind of got a glimpse of in
season one but um
i would love to really kind of encourage
just like what that is and then and
just see where that would go i'm just
excited to play vania
getting more and more badass more
comfortable who she is
happy um you know maybe more of a leader
in many ways